there's like almost 8 billion people in
the world and you're picking this one so
when you marry in theory
like the stocks at its highest like
you're as crazy about each other as you
could possibly be so that's the time to
get into this mindfulness to get into
this practice not once it's like the
wheels are starting to come off it's
much harder it's like gaining a bunch of
weight and saying okay how am I gonna
lose the weight now well I think that
even before marriage like right away
just see everything is beautiful let me
quote BoJack Horseman on this when you
look at someone through Rose Colored
Glasses all the red flags just look like
Flags that's great there's a there's a
certain sense where
if you're from the very beginning of
course you could end up in toxic
relationships that way but
you know life is short you're gonna die
eventually might as well really go all
in on relationships there's a line in uh
Drugstore Cowboy which is great film
where he says we played a game you
couldn't win to the utmost
yeah and I think everything I think life
is a game you can't win and so you play
it to the utmost like to love anything
is insane
because you are accepting that you're
going to lose it
like I I'm a dog person and I and you
you get a dog and you're you've just
resigned yourself to unbelievable pain
because this thing's gonna die in like
10 years maybe 15 if you're lucky
and why would you open your heart to
that why would you let because the joy
is just so wonderful of it the of the of
the ride up until it same thing with us
I mean every marriage every relationship
every love is gonna end it's going to
end in death or divorce so why not like
just go in like go in like go in and
just get get weird you know like don't
Define it the way that's I mean look at
you know again we keep going back to
True Romance but just get weird like
yeah I love this Elvis pretending to be
weirdo I love this like you know like
former sex worker who's like you know
like whatever like just go in like love
this person have them love you don't
worry about what everybody else is doing
in their relationship like we're in such
I mean it's not to me surprising that
that as the performative aspects of Life
on social media increases people's
satisfaction with their relationships
and the divorce rate you know is is
following the same Trend because
I I think everyone's going well what's
everybody else doing you know what how
much sex is everyone else having the
only two people that should worry about
how much sex you're having to two people
if the two people are happy in the
relationship great then what does it
matter what does it matter what
everybody else is doing yeah there
should be an element to Great
relationships and great friendships of
like the world it's US versus us
it's us
like when they're when they're like a
unit like that because it's look it's
just us it's just what we want it's what
we like and that's why I I said like you
know even when it comes to sex or things
like that like if you can't be candid
with your partner about whatever weird
you're into or what fantasy you had
and any particular yeah well no matter
who the hell can you be candid with I
mean because you're gonna either go
without or go elsewhere and neither of
those is a particularly healthy option
or helpful option it's it's the start of
that decline so why why open yourself to
that decline which invariably is just
the path to the chair in front of me in
my office